welcome back to the show now do you guys
notice anything different that's right
we have undergone a rebrand and this
show will no longer be called new
rockstars news but what instead be
called the new rockstars debrief because
that's what we do on this show every
week right we debrief you on the week's
important stuff and if you look closely
there's an important Easter egg in that
title so leave your guesses in the
comments below what that Easter egg is
no one's wearing pants we all debriefed
but we're gonna be talking about a juicy
Avengers in game theory a new tidbit
about the Shazam villain and some
updates on the future of Harley Quinn
and Deadpool I'm Erik Bosse and joining
me today are Sam batcher and Maude
Garrett hello this is Sam welcome I did
because of a new announcement maybe I
could even be American for the first
time what does everyone think about that
smooth transition mid-sentence just go
in and out of there where's that person
from what part of the country is she
from I'm so glad you asked because I am
suburban New Jersey from suburban New
Jersey that's just a moment there we
were in Sopranos anyway some other in
other big news guys big big news the
show is finally a podcast what some of
you may already know that because you're
listening to us rather than like
watching us but you can find the podcast
version of this show on the Himalaya app
Apple podcasts wherever you get your
podcasts that said we would love it if
you got it from the Himalaya app as they
helped us get this audio version off the
ground you can also like follow and
leave comments there get personally
curated playlists and leave us a tip if
you're happy with your service all right
thank you tip your waiters always tip
let's get started with the news from
this week we came across a new theory
about Avengers endgame on reddit this
week from user coolest underscore breezy
and it could be a major game changer for
this final Avengers chapter maybe final
we'll see the
theory suggests that at some point in
the movie The Avengers will have to
appeal to the Living Tribunal now that
is a powerful cosmic being in the comics
for scale you can just see how big he is
because he doesn't have indigestion if
you look below that three little people
it's funny you should mention the word
scale because the living tribunals role
is to judge the universe and keep the
balance in check depending on the writer
at the multiverse - he's living what
happens infinite universes now in the
comics if you read the Infinity Gauntlet
storyline they actually go to Living
Tribunal to try to get to the limit or
beYOU know to judge or prosecute danos
but the limit tribunal where accuses
itself from this process saying that
things didn't break any laws of the
universe would agree with a lot of
murder but I guess survival of the
fittest it's Darwin said it's okay
taking up with a Living Tribunal and
dies disappeared now it does make sense
it's not fair it's really not it does
make sense that the character would need
to get involved after Thinnes made such
a drastic change to this universe of
course but would the Living Tribunal
will be able to undo the snap is that in
their power skill set could the Avengers
really even ask for that would they need
to convince Thanos to make the request
that's probably the most interesting
thing here is this would be a bigger
threat or a bigger force beyond thinness
they'd have to go approach so would they
need to present the united front with
the previous villain with Thanos to
convince him that his snap was a bad
thing and that's one part of it Venice
is an ally right
I mean famous was arguably the
protagonist or the hero of infinity war
will they build on that and make him the
character they have to get on board with
to go talk to some higher power beyond
Thanos tribunal this is just great
theory I really loved that you're
delving deep here and predicting what
could happen and what a fix and solution
could be but when you look at
entertainment and what is entertaining
going to a judge in a universes
courtroom doesn't sound like fun oh come
on
John Grisham has made a lot of books
that made a lot a couple one good movie
yes the course is that the net shoutout
to the net from Sandra Bullock what a
good one
is that Grisham probably not anyways I
also agree with Maude that I there's a
bit of snooze fest but I wouldn't mind
having this character show up because
they already mentioned him in dark
strange which is pretty cool that they
had like a staff to like this is the
staff of the Living Tribunal which is
like saying this paperclip once belonged
to David Bowie it's like it's like this
stick belonged to the judge of the
multiverse he's like what do you do with
it it's like you made it longer or
shorter and it's like okay it's cool as
a visual to see something like that
cosmic and like the scale of it it's
very cool so if you want something to
match the scale of snapping out half of
the universe cool character to pick but
also it's like and I like the idea of
having to convince Santos it's like hey
you may have blown it dude like I mean
you might not be able to get her back
money to move on and maybe you know
fixing just try to make amends I do like
the idea of the Avengers in Thanos being
on the same side so it's no longer a war
between them and there's some kind of
greater problem that they have to
confront together this theory while it's
fascinating reminds me a lot of the
architect in the Matrix Reloaded right
that fascinating act 3 scene that lasted
for 12 minutes with a lot of complicated
words a lot of screens a lot of
conversation and a lot of inactivity and
that would be my concern if that I mean
there are ways you can make this an
active thing that's just like the debate
they're having while they're fighting on
a rooftop somewhere
Wow the fighting on the rooftop is
always the best way they in a movie but
I think there's a reason why the the
comic storyline doesn't really have this
like he Living Tribunal recused himself
because that would be too easy of a fix
if you just had some cosmic entity
decide to flip a switch and that's how
the story gets resolved a problem with
that when all phenyls did was click
really know you don't like you tried to
snap with the metal gauntlet on before
there's no that you can't bend you don't
have you gotta get your kids attention
can't do it when you shout you start an
avalanche and you got a whole different
problem and then everyone gets brushed
down to the resort and when you sit
around the fire have cook I don't like
you know how did we get right here I bet
you on your man's asking the same here
with the MCU right it's a couple simple
words and stories fighting in city
blocks and now we're fighting for the
fate of the universe I will say cause
like when you go big cosmic that's
always some really fun stories like it
turn-turn 'ti over there with his space
on big fan of ham I want to make a
clothing line range like that really
cool and the Living Tribunal is fun he's
cut man he's been hit in the gym he's
been hitting those bars
he's debriefed but I like the character
or the choice of showing that like he's
a three-headed being one of his faces is
covered one is partially covered once
fully seen because he's trying to be
impartial get every side to it it's
listening he's speaking he's seeing you
know here know you Living Tribunal I
hear Living Tribunal and I hear when
boring storylines happened a good movie
franchises
I think Trade Federation I think the
prequel was well you gotta be careful
with like I think you know I I do improv
in there's always an instinct to tag
into a courtroom scene and everyone
thinks oh be so funny to put this person
on trial in this moment as soon as we
all get to that scene it gets real
boring because you realized someone has
to be the stenographer someone has to
sit and be the judge someone's to be the
jury and then people everyone has to
join in I won't get stuck in it forever
I realize the only person who can make
good courtroom drama scripts there's
like Aaron Sorkin where people are
screaming at each other or like for two
minutes and a good episode of Law &
Order SVU and that's the only place
where I want to see it is about two
minutes SVU they do not spend a lot of
time there even though the lawyers
remain care it's just ice tea just like
Mulaney has a great bit on this is like
the first time ice tea has heard of
pedophilia wait a minute so they have to
be like yes iced tea yes yes he has
pictures that are legal but I think this
might be a one of the because comics
things that might just be left alone in
the comics it's hard to depict in a
movie there's no Captain Marvel right in
this whole thing where does she fit it
yeah she's powerful
tribunal exactly let's make her the
villain i I like scale I think that's a
fun I will say the scale of these
characters is fun but you can hit a
point where you can't connect with them
anymore and it's like talking someone
yelling at a tidal wave and that's not
great
I mean it's sometimes fun but if we are
gonna bring back a giant giant villain
it's going to be Galactus that's the way
to go the one I want to see why destroy
half the population when you can eat a
planet guys I'm getting some good
feelings about Galactus coming in
because they Kevin Feige just mentioned
Galactus at the red carpet he just made
a cameo in Adam McKay's movie Vice the
were like yeah he just he compared Dick
Cheney to Galactus devourer of world
worlds but in order to get that
reference apparently they had to go
through foggy to get him to sign off on
it which i think is interesting because
it's still currently a Fox Marvel
property why would they go through Feige
for it if unless we're gonna see the
Silver Surfer is what you're trying to
tell me that's after and that is the
debrief Easter Egg debrief no you
doesn't need them doesn't need him in
space no no he's good to go we got to
see a good version of clock that's right
rise of the Silver Surfer really just
made him a cloud an impersonal cloud
that turtleneck sweater boy it is yeah
yeah I think it's weird to see this day6
mocking a divine intervention you gotta
be really careful that how you'd bring
it into a story like gives me the animal
series no I did I love those books but
there are these cosmic deities called
like the elements in the crack I might
be mispronouncing it cuz I just read it
but they're real people are really mad
one person's really excited they wrote
about their gods basically their gods in
the universe of the Animorphs and they
start picking sides in the war between
the Animorphs in new york's and then
there's some crazy stories where they
they basically pick champions to fight
to see if they can win their weird chess
game between each other and it took me
out I'm glad that that didn't become a
regular thing but that all miss keeps
coming back
and it it maybe kind of worked in the
books
it wouldn't work in the TV or movie
adaptation of Anna Moore's that needs to
happen let's get on this right right
damn straight we need simply returning
these animals slowly there you go you
know it's great and and Cassie makes it
beautiful and the rest should be ugly I
want to see an ugly morph into animals
yeah go for it
and also this I think honestly just like
slight slight side note some people want
to make some it's like when people want
to make a Sandman movie Neil Gaiman is
like vertigo comic because that's a
there they make a whole new category for
those characters and they're the endless
and they're easily just like concepts of
like ones death ones dream ones desires
one list and it's just like begin to try
to imagine you trying to make a
two-and-a-half-hour movie outside this
big you would they do in the story but
also they have like this scale to them
that's like their endless that's the
point of them that they like they they
have personalities but kind of not cuz
they're just kind of like an idea I feel
personally attacked about scale
I mean I'm 511 I can I managed to joke
from time to time I why are you gonna
bring me into this dude well cuz you
never gave me piggyback rides that's
because your skin so yeah great concepts
don't always make great characters in
movies I think that's one thing to keep
in mind though it could appear and it
could be awesome and I don't know
snapping away half the universe would
make sense in a movie and they made it
work hey that living tributyl better
because he better be frickin shredded
like for sure yeah like dr. Manhattan oh
like two giant floppy blue yeah how do
you do this week's trivia question shall
we gang if you guys are new year we ask
a trivia question once a week winner
gets to be the king of the show they get
to eat all the food and the scrumptious
treats but the loser has to humiliate
themselves with the gif of shame shame
shame no one said the reverberation and
shadow who's this young chap that made
this trial yes for the listeners what a
man
yes we've got a delightful box with
funnel knickknacks on it which you can
see the result of on our Twitter at new
rock stars but yes when we ask you a
trivia question we gonna write the
answer we'll figure out who's gonna have
to pull an embarrassing act out of the
gif of shame box and perform in front of
all of us for us to giggle and who will
be the king with all the treats alright
first up this is a this one kids which
of these three quotes are from the
Living Tribunal Oh which of the four
which of the three these quotes which of
these quotes are from the Living
Tribunal there's four options we have to
pick her out figure out which one that's
right actually from the Living Tribunal
yes coming all of our favorite
characters The Living Tribunal all right
first up a we are an impossibility in an
impossible universe what B power is
meaningless beyond this level of
existence C the universe is under no
obligation to make sense to you and D
those who want to live let them fight
and those who do not want to fight in
this world of eternal struggle do not
deserve to live that's a yikes for me on
that last one so one more time which of
these quotes are from the Living
Tribunal a we are an impossibility in an
impossible universe B power is a
meaningless power is meaningless beyond
this level of existence C the universe
is under no obligation to make sense to
you and D those who want to live let
them fight and those who do not want to
fight in a world of eternal struggle do
not deserve to live that's a yikes for
me but also living tribunal is sometimes
a yikes character so go ahead and write
that's a B C or D just make it a little
bit easy on yourselves or one two three
four well that's it for the trivia gang
I made that as hard as possible for
everyone but let's go ahead and tell
those kiddies new things about Shazam
shall we we should but before we get to
that we got to give a quick shout-out
and a thank you to stitch picks for
helping us out by sponsoring this video
stitch fix is an online personal styling
service that finds clothes shoes and
accessories that look good on you and
fit your budget and they send them to
your door it's great if you're a busy
guy or busy gal someone like me and your
parents no longer buy your clothes for
you now to sign up you just got to go
stitch fix calm slash
rock stars and answer some questions
about your sizes style and how much you
want to spend and then you get paired
with a stylus which is super helpful for
maybe is I don't know what I'm doing and
they hand pick five items and they send
them to your door you try on everything
at home and you keep what you like and
you return the rest shipping exchanges
returns they're all free by the way and
there's also no subscription required
you can sign up for scheduled shipments
but you can also request a fix as they
call them whenever you want there is a
twenty dollar styling fee but its
applied toward any of the stuff that you
keep I've got some stuff on the way that
I'm super excited about so keep an eye
on our future videos to follow along
with my style evolution and get started
on yours now it's ditch Vic's comm slash
rockstars you'll get an extra 25% off
when you keep all five items in your box
that's stitch fix comm slash rock stars
to get started today stitch fix comm
slash rock stars tell us about what's
going on with Shazam I'm so excited for
this movie Shazam is going to be a blast
because we got a teaser this week and
made me just giddy and that movies
coming up fast comes up April 5th of
2009 teen and along with the teaser yes
I'm close with the date pretty close and
along with the teaser that Eric went way
too into in his breakdown on our YouTube
channel a bunch of interviews with the
cast and crew dropped this week very
exciting we of course read them all very
closely and one thing jumped out in an
interview with Mark Strong when my
favorite actors and actor he's playing
dr. thaddeus sivana the bad guy in this
film he said this when talking about his
character's powers he gets to fly he can
create electrical fields with his hands
and fire electricity
I love the whole notion that in his eye
he has seven sins that manifests
themselves at various points whatever
they or he wants them to now we got the
seven deadly sins what are they again oh
there you go new pride lust lust sloth
dancer Prancer vixen rudolph
the ninth that's one of the least
important range
they're drivin bees up there got it rat
yes of course now we got introduced to
the sins in the most recent trailer but
it's really quick we can see that Billy
is sinning by some statues that kind of
look like gargoyle right now that show
great that's a good show those right
there then you have them those are them
but I don't think we knew that they were
going to be living in dr. sivanna's eye
that's new any thoughts on how this is
gonna work gang okay so if there's two
gargoyles that live within is I this is
I'm getting verse seven the seven in
there but the gargoyles okay so in might
with the gargoyles do you remember
flotsam and jetsam now I've got our boys
the bus is on a roll that's all I'm
singing get it's from easy this is from
dope it's a widow mom Wade yes the Eels
that she controls is going to be like
that so like these things can pop out
and deploy them out in the world like
the well in the comics they've been
imprisoned in stone like we see them
here but Shazam by Shazam the wizard
he's the one who imprisoned them
thousands of years ago she's in exactly
by no no the usually he goes by the name
just the wizard but originally when
Shazam was Captain Marvel the wizard got
the name Shazam so Shazam the wizard has
the power of Shazam who gives it to
Shazam aka Captain Marvel this is like
Aquaman where everyone has named some
version of a plan something
sentence yes thank you it's it's it's
around about one yeah but this this like
Pandora opened the box and these seven
deadly sins got out thousands of years
ago and they hunted them down and then
he encased them in stone but now it's
sounding like they got out again or
maybe they're changing that to work with
young Savannah who did that since well
this is based on the new 52 run which is
such a good storyline for Shazam but
it's it's clearly they're kind of
revamping it a little bit in that comic
Savannah accidentally lets Black Adam
out and he's a nightmare and that's what
allows his eye to turn all blue because
he can now see magic and understand what
magic means in the black is Dwayne the
rock Johnson he is that's why I'm like
there's no way we're not gonna see him
in at least in a post-credits in this
movie
they uh they also work with the seven
deadly sins and release the mountain to
the world but the in that story the
seven deadly sins take over one like
Avatar like this one evil dude in the
town and he becomes like this giant
demon which I really fun so if you want
to just kind of streamline all that into
one character good call and it's cool
that they managed that manifests
themselves whenever they or he wants
them to so that they kinda are actually
in the driver's seat even though he
feels like he is really kind of feels
like demonic possession right like he's
got these seven demonic entities that
can pop out of his eye and infect
something else I wonder if they're tying
it in like in the comics the new 52
comics that I helped some see like
hidden magic that no one else can what
if he's able to see like the presence of
Envy in someone and use that to
manipulate glass yeah yeah maybe an
insensible
yeah and use that to manipulate people
that's like you're a lustful person
let's see what we can do with this that
feels pretty evil what happens if we get
a post-credits scene and it is black
Adam but the same fate happens as Jess
stroke in the yes Justice League scene
and we don't hear from him or see him
ever again
it couldn't hey time will tell I feel
like there it's gonna happen
I I would love a tease like that and I
like the idea that like it kind of seems
like a symbiote with the demons like the
seven deadly sins within him and I'd
like to see them manifest through him
differently because Mark Strong is such
a strong
that's a mode actor thank you appreciate
it
no I'd like to see him kind of like it
in a venom or like upgrade kind of style
of like personifying be is like I think
that the most extreme version of Wrath
or greed or lust lust will be a weird
one or gluttony
like that I would like to see stuff
something like yeah imagine being the
person who has to carry the source of
all these seven deadly sins that are out
around the world you carry the source of
these monsters inside you at all times
you probably be a bad person yeah need
seven different particular ways and
you'd be proud of it you have to carry
that burden
are you and angry and bit envious for
people who don't have it yeah yeah it's
full yeah it'd be cool to see the
different ways that can manifest and
Mark strong is a very talented actor I
could see him playing all seven of those
different things in the interesting way
it's his version of split I'm extremely
excited for this movie and the addition
of the seven deadly sins all you got to
do is is one movie with them and never
touch them again DC try to make them
more important and literally they
whiffed it hard in the comics so leave
it to them let us know what you guys
think in the comments down below because
I'm excite for this movie and I want it
to be good it can be really great we're
doing an album later don't spoil oh yeah
well some other stuff came out this week
about Deadpool
oh now the original plan for Deadpool
was apparently to release the x-force
movie from writer and director Drew
Goddard next and then three following
you know the whole I'm in one arm and
two Avengers I'm in three oh yeah okay
according to the writer Rhett Reese
that's what he was saying the whole
theory was but just a few weeks ago we
heard reports that the x-force movie was
a no-go due to the Disney Fox merger so
the fate of the x-force movie is now
unclear how do you feel about that I
like your Godard man everything that guy
makes is he maybe should he can't touch
Marvel stuff yeah you should just finish
daredevil man blew it oh well no you're
great you're very tanky got cursed
because he walked away from it maybe
yeah nobly anyway at an event in China a
few days ago though the Deadpool star
himself and producer Ryan Reynolds gave
a loaded update about Deadpool 3 he said
my team uh hold on my team was already
had work on Deadpool 3 but looking to go
in a completely different direction
often they say something funny
often they reboot or change a character
maybe like four movies too late I was
like asterisks say something funny like
he would have said something funny then
if it was really Ryan Reynolds got
equipment the harder you have it I was
trying to impersonate him there you go
pretty good thank you for my asterisks
and understanding it
so basically they're saying they're not
gonna do what a lot of movie franchises
do yeah they're gonna pivot perfect what
do you think's happening which I pull
three since I already thought that
Deadpool two was quite different enough
from the original one it was pretty
different I think Ryan oh good
they had a kid they brought in a
foul-mouthed kid I think Ryan Reynolds
brings up a good point that they do wait
too long they wait till they beat I care
a version of a character to death yeah
until they decide to reset it I don't
know what other directions because right
now like two movies in I don't think
they're forming patents yet right
yeah the two line or two points make a
line but not a pattern you need three to
make a pattern yeah do a trilogy well
maybe he doesn't necessarily mean like
well maybe it means like rather than a
big team up movie which is what the
x-force is gonna be anymore more
characters it could have just been a
simple smaller story read between the
lines guys oh yeah but it's not a major
reset it kind of seems like that was on
the wall and he he wasn't really
integral to the second one but he did
have a big role in that one though yeah
but I think they reduced it considerably
since TJ's been in some hot water yeah
this is a pretty good way to say that
characters we don't want to over user so
maybe that might be they're doing with
everybody though like maybe let's
defender less Vanessa less like what I'm
thinking is maybe they might do
something like Logan just him and the
kid in the woods somewhere and that's
the new virgin oh my god okay so here
you go it's dead it's dead pools Logan
its Wade whatever you want to call it
who cares and it's end of the world all
the x-men are dead but it's just like
him long beard like crazy apocalypse not
like dystopian America it's like
wasteland like everything's desert we
have to trade soda with I don't know
radioactive jewels or you know video
game logic yeah there you go
and teaming up with a young girl and
then the time travel back and reset the
whole thing yeah I mean ripples
perfectly set up to go crazy and to like
do full-on parody movies that aren't
necessarily because if you think both of
his movies are parodies of superhero
movies why not do a parody of another
genre do that parody of a rom-com that
the first deadpool promised it was gonna
be
loved the romance moments and then they
Vanessa was huddling in the second one I
felt that they tried to do a compilation
group instead and they didn't even last
long either he got to go to heaven
though a couple times some pretty mean
to heaven what was your idea that you
might know about he can't die
I didn't even put that together my brain
that he is the ultra healing ability so
he can outlive everyone else in his life
kind of like Logan's got the healing
collar on which is only way you could
get through really good MacGuffin yeah
buddy cop drama with him and Hugh
Jackman all right I'm done there you go
I think you solved it I think that's the
new direction they think I've ever said
Oh that'd be a bigger reaction
we're so shocked we're so stunned yeah
there it is
put it all together coming up we're
gonna reveal the answer to a trivia
question catch you guys up on the rest
of the week's news including DC's plans
for a surprise new movie trilogy not as
fun as this trilogy is right here but
first a shout-out to this week's final
sponsor care of Kara is a service that
makes it delivers personalized vitamins
now it's only January so there's plenty
of time to start getting into the
healthy thing that we all promised we're
gonna do and already forgot about with
care of it's super easy they even come
in these convenient little packets I
feel little perkier today honestly and
they even make taking your vitamins fun
there's an online quiz where they ask
you about your diet and your goals and
they put together the exact right
vitamin concoction for you and they've
got an app you can track your progress
and earn rewards for remembering to take
your vitamins it's nice to get a pat on
the back for doing the right thing once
in a while alright and if you're vegan
or vegetarian they have options for you
as well to like balance everything that
you need and take advantage of this
month's special new year offer for 50%
off your first month of personalized
care of vitamins go to take care of comm
and enter rockstars fifty again that's
take care of comm and rock stars fifty
four half off your first month of
vitamin bottle up kids go ahead and
click click and don't look like one more
time because in other news we've got our
first look at Jon Cryer aka the nerdy
one from Two and a Half Men as Lex
Luthor in
supergirl the CW hit for our audio
listeners he looks like Jon Cryer but
bald and wearing a jumpsuit it is a
statement you can say Jon Cryer without
cry a little bit
lit I'll be honest you got a point there
I just sometimes you just never know how
big a person's head is anyways they also
in the news a sequel to be humble be as
vodka earlier the best of the
Transformers franchise is actually very
good news yeah was it 6th time is a
charm
yes also this is the franchise that they
wanted to death and didn't change and
resurrect the character so Ryan Reynolds
hates transformers whoa confirm yeah
also a Harley Quinn trilogy is rumored
to be in the works because of course it
is and someone dug up some old Justice
League concept arts art pieces that show
off an early version of Aquaman's suit
they were closer to the characters look
in the comments it's the green bottoms
orange top all the scales that a young
boy could ever want for his clothes
which is very fun I think you're ready
for this scaly I'm not but what I am
ready for is lightning round we will hit
you up every single Friday the u.s. time
for full lightning around questions all
you got to do is tweet them at us at new
rock stars now I'm gonna read them out
fire them in my co-hosts that you
directed the Matt they have to answer
them as quickly as possible otherwise I
will physically slap them not know it
this is what's gonna happen all right
Sam it's from at CJ's alter ego ICJ says
explain to me why cyclopses eyes don't
burst from the pressure build-up of his
concussive blasts furthermore how does
he see in general the ruby courts visor
just blocks and stores concussive energy
which means he's firing at all times
right right note their little portals
that open to another dimension of
Crimson energy and also comic book
yeah I withdraw my question yes a truce
gone hatred gordon the eye of agamotto
is a key artifact for Doctor Strange do
you think we'll be restored or charged
after avengers endgame oh I have a
komodo without the without the time
stone no I don't think it well I think
it's only purpose is to I know in the
comics it's a big deal but I think in
the MCU the eye of agamotto is only a
vessel or an encasement for the time
stone so I see no reason why I see no
reason why all right
overruled well at cloudy one and only
said to me who do you guys see dying in
the next Star Wars film Leia
it's sad but you're right that is the I
went way too logical and not enough
empathy on Lena
Terry Oh Lane Lane nope l'ainte are real
i dad won this have hawk-i and bulls-eye
ever gone toe-to-toe in the comics Oh
eivol eivol always tie except I usually
pulls what a quick one overall there's
always two they have good aim
Erik you're up at the awesome iron piece
says hey what's gonna be an unexpected
hit in 2019 movie TV showed game
whatever you can think of unexpected in
it hit in 2019 is your face Dark Phoenix
I think we're gonna love it oh really
mutants huh more Tom fire eight us you
John weak versus a Punisher who wins I'm
gonna say John weak that guy doesn't die
he had every deadly assassin in the
earth after him he's still alive well in
the Punishers mind everyone is trying to
kill him actually not at all
it's not
assassins have bullets but yeah it's
like stormtroopers are after him you
know yeah all right Eric I got nothing
for you
you ready at G and Noel no what do you
think the world looks like three visions
eyes analytics slash robotic like javis
all romantic slash supernatural because
of the stern um I think the stone I
think the stone is more visions
personality because I think it looks
confusing I think everything looks sad I
bet he sees things like through the eyes
of dr. Manhattan but a little bit more
optimistic because he wore sweater on
his shoulders
yes where he had to manifest the sweater
on his shoulders he does maybe a little
rose-colored vision tell us 93 says if
you had the choice to improve your eyes
from one of three animal traits zooming
long distance sight from Eagles night
vision from owls or greater color
perception from mantis shrimp which
would you choose
I get the one where I don't eat classes
I want the shrimp because I want to see
26 different colors I didn't know this
Chris could see more colors and mixers
how many colors are there more infinite
they could see a lot more infinite yeah
you don't even know man you know I got
one last one from an undiscussed walk
hey Nathan who's a fictional character
you just want to punch in the face need
nom that's all I'm saying
cool let's move on is that the cat the
co-captain returned the Jedi yes his
lips were just always moist his bottom
lip was like yeah it's been a long day
and I'm a survivor force awakens did we
ever get clearance or him huh we saw him
he was so a lot of pilots died in that
replay patents doctrine you know de to
bring us those movies with the buttons
now both hands who knows often well now
comes the time for a 15-second shout-out
where each of us is 15 seconds to shout
out plug or ramble about anything Sam oh
ok so at first episode
doesn't come out yet but david tennant
does a podcast wid thought thought
thought is the name of david tennant's
new podcast and i want to listen to it
and i hope it's good yet 50 i'll jump in
okay i'm hosting a live comedy show
every first Friday the month called
darkest timeline comedy I'm so excited
we're gonna do a showcase of crazy nerd
bits you're gonna see some familiar
faces from this channel our first one
February first mods gonna be there Phil
it's gonna be there Talia Bechtol is
gonna be there and a bunch of my
favorite comedians doing some of the
craziest bits in the strangest universe
be there acme NoHo in APM yep i want to
give a shout out to Dobby I'm reading
Harry Potter and the Deathly Hallows
part-2 and yeah it's just one book but
it's actually the end of part one I'm
reading the book and the way that he
does is so sad and the funeral is just
really hard and it's a sight you know
what he fought slavery you know he
actually became a free elf and he chose
to help Harry and it was a little bit
obsessive let's be honest here but I
just feel like he's a bit of an unsung
hero so I wanted to give him his shaft
I think he's adequately sung I was happy
to see him go and I hated that subplot
in the books and I'm frustrated that his
character was in the movies at all oh
yeah slaves in her mind he's an activist
creates you to try to fight these elf
slavery it's a very noble thing except
for the fact that you know Rowling's
analogy is that certain races of people
are elves if we're comparing this to the
real world I'm not crazy about someone
rolling it's political beliefs but
whatever just what-what are the goblins
of Gringotts they're bankers they embody
certain stereotypes of other races of
things and they're bankers and they're
greedy and they're horrible people think
about it too hard and all of your
favorite authors are monsters someone
once told me that every female adult in
Harry Potter movie is basically destined
to be in the kitchen well they are Molly
and then flare in that book she's she's
making a Buddha for everyone when Harry
and Ron and Hermione go off who's
cooking the food that'd be Hermione like
doesn't Harry see Jenny's
value when she bakes him things isn't
that part of her value
hey Hermione Granger becomes Minister of
Magic in the curse child we don't talk
about the coast child day I don't talk
about we could I don't think so we could
spend days talking about Christie if we
want to take digs to comics used to be
super racist but all that though let's
go ahead and move back to our trivia
question all right so I asked the
question what's your favorite line from
The Living Tribunal from the comics we
all got the question we've had the
answer to this huh well we've already
had it we've all had our favorite for
decades the answer here but I'll
reiterate the question before we read
off each other's the question is would
you be required in the Living Tribunal a
what are we are an impossibility in an
impossible universe it's not favorite
quote it's the only what is something
that your family said it's your favorite
this is saying that someone's opinion is
wrong which is the thing that we fight
against the most on the Internet
the power is meaningless oh the answer
so yeah yes okay be be power is
meaningless beyond this level of
existence see the universe is under no
obligation makes sense to you and it's
talking to me and II those who want to
live let them fight and those who do not
want to fight in this world of eternal
struggle do not deserve to live
and that's for me now the wrong guest
answer you will have to draw a task or
gesture from the gif of shame container
and perform said task repeatedly while
the winner gets to read the goodbyes and
we chant shame at you which is always a
blast so let's go ahead it's pretty cool
cuz your stupidity gets turned into an
animated gif which will blast out on our
social media to punish you for your
trivia ignorance now for the audio
listeners you can just follow us on
Twitter at new rock so to see what the
heck we're talking about
so we reiterated the question let's go
around I'm going to read mods
answer further apologize about the
picture that I drew I really wasn't my
best I thought it would help the
situation but in hindsight it doesn't
look great you said be power
it'd be you said powers meaningless
beyond this level of existence alright
also said beam I'd Ruby you did drop and
you wrote not my beast which would have
been a way to save it but he wrote bears
not draw B I came up with a pun this
time the universe is and no obligation
to make sense to you pretty good but
gang buckle up on your buckles because
we have an answer here in three two go
it is B power is meaningless but beyond
this level of existence that's from the
Living Tribunal we are an impossibility
in an impossible universe is from Ray
Bradbury the universe is under no
obligation makes sense to you is from
Neil deGrasse Tyson and those who want
to live in and then let them find
uninviting the world is from Adolf
Hitler oh that's why I gave those a few
yikes
throughout the show no Sam and that
means sure known I just reread Infinity
Gauntlet just sounds like something he
would have said very well chosen quote
those were good work everyone behind a
camera preciate it now Eric what did you
bid well I picked from the gift of shame
bucket
cry whilst flossing do cry while
flossing devotees yes lots of blood
comes out of those teeth very cool and
while we do that we're going clear this
way you know I've been 27 a few times
and I still don't have any cavities
that's pretty cool
I had a bunch as a kid because I was bad
child which is fun let's go ahead and
read our good-byes while Eric makes us
proud you know thank you for watching
this week's episode of new rock stars
hey breathe yeah I want to thank our
host Sam bastard we know yeah I also won
so I too am a winner and Eric Voss is
embarrassing himself
lately this is amazing you can find him
at a TA voice to be like that's not how
you floss my man that is crying stand
back that wretch is that up samba I'm at
mud dirt to St T's ei Voss more like ei
floss so the quick writer that these are
also available in audio and video form
videos at youtube.com slash me rock
stars and you get the audio anywhere you
get your podcast but if you would you
use the Himalaya app you can actually
leave comments on the episodes and
support the show directly which ain't
that fun gang big fan of that comment
tweet us and new rock stars like this
video or a podcast share it around and
subscribe the new rock stars for deep
dives into the stuff that you love he
keeps doing this and not from that was
the Elaine 10 that is the language no oh
my gosh I am now the more winner out of
the two so that'd be me winning
completely thanks Sam for coming in
second place someone had to come in Phil
well you know I'll be silver sofa thank
you I am usually not number one but hey
gang we appreciate you and we'll see you
next time bye bye no bye bye
that's drunk uncle at the wedding I
don't know Peter I've never met Peter
emo P welcome